I believe I will start I spent a good
deal of the of the lecture on Tuesday
taking issue with the chapter on the
Latin West from 1200 to 1500 in the
earth and its people's
and that was entirely warranted it's a
badly written and badly conceived
chapter nonetheless it is apparent that
something happened in Europe that is a
historical moment and that during this
period between 1200 and 1500 Europe
seems to have to use a sort of 20th
century phrase taken off some things
start to happen more dynamically in
certain parts of Europe than before and
it leads on to the Reformation to the
Scientific Revolution to the Industrial
Revolution to Imperial greatness to
European domination of the world etc etc
nobody really disagrees that something
happens at some point that sets Europe
on a track that is of great historical
importance there is profound
disagreement on the question of what it
was that happened in Europe and when it
happened there are a number of theories
that have been put forward and debated
and some of those theories are somewhat
more plausible and others but it's also
clear that there are many other theories
that are possible that have not been
explored as much one of the most obvious
theories is the notion of the
relationship between capitalism and the
Protestant Reformation now to be sure
that takes place in the 1500s
not in the period covered by this
chapter but if you're going to look at
the question of when did Europe undergo
a significant change of direction or
acceleration in a particular direction
you you have to look at a continuum you
can't simply pick a date and say well
it's this or that
the debate over Protestantism and the
spirit of capitalism focuses on the work
of the sociologist and sociological
historian mocs Faber and it presumes
that the religious views of Protestants
as determined by the theological views
of their ecclesiastical leaders had an
impact upon their performance upon the
way they led their life in the real
world and the view that Weber singles
out is the notion of predestination and
the idea that some people from the
moment of birth and the moment of
conception were destined for paradise
that you could not alter God's will and
that it was implausible that God would
inflict upon people who were destined
for paradise material impoverishment in
this world and that therefore if you you
may not know whether you were destined
for paradise but if you did well in this
world it would appear to improve the
chances of your doing well in the next
world and therefore Protestants were
inclined to to become successful
businessman investors off-roaders and so
forth
many many different objections can be
made to this and the reason it became so
important as a view in the 1950s in
particular was that it appealed to
Western and particularly to American
sociologists and historians because it
suggested that the behavior of people in
the in the economic life was a function
of their religious beliefs what made
that important was because it was the
reverse of what Karl Marx had advocated
that is to say that the the
infrastructure the mode of production
and the position of any individual
within a class struggle is basically the
determinant of how they behave in this
world and the theology or religious
rituals that they engage in are a kind
of super structural epiphenomena of no
intrinsic importance they can be an
opiate for the masses perhaps or they
can be simply a display of class
privilege for the feudal elite but but
belief does not determine economic
behavior and Weber was saying that
belief does determine economic behavior
so in the context of the Cold War
particularly in the United States which
was far less influenced at the level of
intellectual endeavor than Europe by
Marxism as I say most intellectuals in
Europe were to some degree oriented
toward Marxism or specifically away from
Marxism whereas the Marxist tendency in
the United States remained very limited
and here was Weber a bona fides German
scholar of highest rank and
accomplishment who was saying that
marx had it backwards this doesn't mean
that weber was right and and so you had
other people who who took other views as
to what happened to change europe and
they were less perhaps influential at a
broad intellectual point of view because
their views did not in particular no
coincide with the grand ideological
struggles of the 20th century but from
it from a historical point of view you
have to look at what some of the other
possibilities were the one that has
gotten so much play in the last few
years particularly since 9/11 is the
idea that borrowings from the Muslim
world where the trigger that that set
European European track those borrowings
have been focused on science and
philosophy and medicine and we have
ample documentation of the translation
into Latin of works on medicine
philosophy and science and of the
movement of these works into the
curricula of the universities that were
coming to be founded in Europe and
indeed it's been argued particularly by
the late George back to say about the
universities of Europe were actually
patterned on the meddra tsa's or the
colleges of the Muslim world and that
the whole notion of higher education
moving out of the monastery and into the
university was a borrowing from the film
nowadays the notion of borrowing from
the Muslim world has expanded a good
deal from you know it is not opposed to
anything that has been said previously
with regard to science or theology or
philosophy or medicine but rather it now
takes in a great deal more in the area
of everyday culture and technology of
manufacturing so that the introduction
of new industries of the earth the paper
industry and these are things have
happened in the time period covered by
this chapter 2002 15 1200 to 1500 that
is to say before the crops of the
Reformation before the period that weber
picked out as the crucial period you
have the introduction of a paper making
industry which is accompanied by the
introduction of printing the first
unquestionably of borrowing from the
Muslim world and the second in all
likelihood at least a partial borrowing
from the Muslim world so that you have a
new medium for the dissemination of
ideas and opinions through printed texts
and even when they were not printed
through the abundant availability of
paper which was far more far cheaper and
more easy to accept to access than than
parchment you had a cotton industry that
starts in northern Italy in the in the
14th century the cotton industry is
borrowed from the Muslim world
you will find a great deal written in
standard history books of Europe about
the wool industry particularly between
Britain and Flanders and the the sale of
woolens you find very little written
about the sale of Cotton's
the even though for southern Europe
Cotton's obviously were a were a major
improvement in the types of fabrics
available you have a silk industry that
gets introduced from the Middle East in
the Islamic world you have a a sugar
industry that has introduced sugars
introduced primarily from Egypt it gets
transferred onto islands in the
Mediterranean particularly Cyprus under
Italian control slaves are used to
produce sugar and this becomes the model
that is then shifted to the islands of
the Atlantic like the Canary Islands and
Cape Verde and so forth and then from
there to the islands of the Caribbean so
the the Caribbean sugar industry which
becomes the economic mainstay of Western
European imperial domains is a borrowing
from the Muslim Muslim world soap making
comes in from the Muslim world a huge
change in the ceramics industry with a
far more complex and versatile glazing
techniques borrowed from from Muslim
sources glass particularly in Venice a
new wave of glass making an expansion of
Oh glass making glass baking techniques
you have in the Renaissance the the lute
becomes the standard instrument for you
know the casual romantic who wants to
entertain his ladylove and the lute is
simply a version of the Arabic stringed
instrument would allude becomes becomes
Luke there are verse forms that get
transferred from Arabic in Spain or a
mixture of Arabic and Romance language
in Spain into French and Italian there
are food imports that become important
is this is the period when pasta enters
into into Italy it is not wanton
imported from China it is Greek imported
from North Africa and it's fairly clear
when you read you know recent books on
the history of pasta that this is a
borrowing across the Mediterranean from
North Africa into southern Europe so
what you have now with a lot of Muslim
intellectuals and with some
justification is the thought that the
the take-off of Europe into what becomes
a role as the the vanguard of modernity
was provided by the Muslims and that
they provided the springboard that
allowed Europe to take off that number
of works has been written recently
touching upon this and there's a good
deal of historical classification the
response of from Islamophobes is that so
you were creative a thousand years ago
like we care you know if if all these
things were a springboard to modernity
why didn't you do it yourself you lazy a
Rams you it's it's become highly
politicized and this politicization is
kind of a mirror of the politicization
you've had between Marx and Weber Marx
and Weber you had the idea that you had
the Eastern communists that had a
clearly inferior philosophy of Marxism
that stressed the infrastructural role
whereas in the West we had Weber who
taught us to value our religious beliefs
our spiritual superstructure and this
was in the Cold War now we have the idea
of people in the East but then now the
Muslim East rather than communist East
saying we're the ones who gave you
modernity and the people in the West
saying you may have had something to do
with the roots of modernity but you
couldn't do anything with it because you
are not up to the task so history
historiography gets
involved in the current political
disputes then there there are other
approaches to it one of the best-known
has to do with the birth of the the
subfield of history which is history of
science history of science stresses that
it is during this period during the 15th
century and then the 16th century that
you have the challenge to the Ptolemaic
view of the world or the universe which
saw the which visualized all of the the
planets the moon and all the planets of
the Sun revolving around the earth and
replacing it with the Copernican system
of the earth and the other heavenly orbs
with the acceptable moon which does
revolve around the earth all revolving
the Sun the heliocentric system they say
that this is the this is the
intellectual trigger that sets people
moving from time to time I have proposed
to scholarly colleagues European
historians that they that they could
consider a thought experiment in which
it is cloudy every night in Europe from
14 USA from 1350 to 1550 sunshine during
the day no problem with that but it just
clouds up every night kind of like San
Francisco with the the fog coming in
every every evening over the Golden Gate
and it just was powdery every night so
nobody could observe the movements of
heavenly bodies so there couldn't have
been a Tycho Brahe hey or a Copernicus
and ultimately the observations that
Newton used to to
ferm his ideas about the law of gravity
would not have been available
supposing you simply could not have had
observation Allah strana me over this
crucial period what the history of
Europe have been different and when I
raise this question the people who who
are willing to take such silliness
seriously divided into two camps the one
camp that says yes this would have
changed everything because if the
Copernican system had not come to be
postulated and accepted the church would
have remained dominant and it was only
by dethroning the church that that the
modern world could come into being and
they don't see any other any other
example of how the church could have
been dethroned you know what other
doctrine of the church could have been
so so indisputably challenged and
refuted as the Ptolemaic notion of an
earth-centered universe the other
response I get is well now that you
asked me to consider it there really are
almost no spin-off technologies or
spin-off effects from observational
astronomy as there are today I mean no
unless we happen to spot asteroid
heading toward the earth and we have to
send Bruce Willis up to get rid of it
but but by and large observational
astronomy is kind of a charming pastime
that produces profound but ultimately
not very important ideas it doesn't
create new industries it doesn't employ
tons of people and so this camp would
say even if there had been no Copernican
system Europe would have gone on its own
plate it was it was
on a path and it didn't depend upon that
and they if they want to engage the
issue of the church they would argue no
regardless of the Copernican system the
challenge to the church was going to
take place because the the debate that
was stimulated more than anything or as
much as anything by the translations
from arabic
the debate over nominalism and realism
was a crucial philosophical debate that
ultimately the nominalist won so that a
unknow man in latin is a name it's also
the word for a noun and so a nominal
position said that the absolute entities
that platonic thinking encourages or
indeed requires that you believe
happiness goodness numbers forms of
everything
all of these abstract invisible forms
that Plato requires to exist in order
for you to understand the material world
about you so you you only know that this
is a table because it shares certain
attributes with all other things that
you call table and those attributes all
relate to an unseen absolute of table
'no stat is existent someplace okay
phenomena lists said that
table is simply a noun it isn't a thing
you know that's a table ness is not a
thing it is simply a made simply a noun
there is no abstract invisible no
supernal eternal table that is out there
as Plato argues so a real list and here
this is one of the many meanings of the
word realists that have evolved over
over time nowadays say it's a big term
in international relations theory but
for the 14th 15th century a realist was
someone who said the the the platonic
forms are real they actually exist
they are simply invisible but the
absolutes exist so then it's out of this
kind of debate that you've got the issue
of how many angels can dance on the head
of a pin our angels real or as angel
just a word the the radical nominalist
who William of Occam
becomes the the best-known the radical
nominalist said let's look at everything
in the simplest possible way and simply
not presume that there are platonic
absolutes let's just take treat things
as nouns and out of this arose to a
large degree experimental science which
said well let's just see what there
really is that is real in the material
sense not real in the absolute platonic
sense and deduce things from that so
somebody who wanted to challenge the
role of the Copernican universe at the
central center of of intellectual change
could be challenged from the point of
view of the nominal as saying that
regardless of the of the movement of the
heavenly spheres we are going to to
change our way of thinking and you have
much more importance to the material you
know the demonstrable material
surroundings that we live in on this
planet and we're not going to to pay
that much attention to the notion of
abstract things and of course one of the
things about the heavenly spheres was
what are they are they you know fiery
balls are they crystal balls are they
simply bright spots that are being that
are moving as part of a huge crystalline
sphere the Copernican system didn't
really clarify all of that although
Galileo by observing the moons of
Jupiter and the irregularities of the
surface and so forth pretty
well-established that they were the
planets at least were trest real but the
the Stars remained enigmatic but
the the nominalist said let's deal with
this world and they would have said that
regardless of what was happening of
level of science so you have history of
science theory that says that astronomy
is everything and arguments made against
that you have a political economy theory
saying that it is Protestant thought
that is dominant and that doesn't fit
Drake
well chronologically what was what was
happening you have a Muslim borrowing
theory that works pretty well for the
Renaissance but doesn't explain things
very well after the Renaissance kind of
Peters out which if it does by the you
know by the late 16th century so we we
don't have a very clear notion of what
it was that happened in Europe and there
probably a half dozen other theories
that might be that might be talked about
that would suggest something that
happened that move things that move
things along in a way not previously
anticipated I'm gonna talk about one of
them because I like to not because it is
necessarily the most provable of the lot
but what I'm going to talk about is a
wheel transportation
the first
carriage the first passenger carriage in
England was apparently imported from
Holland
in in the 1550s the Queen Elizabeth
observing it decided that she would
order a carriage for herself but before
that time carriages were were rare we're
unknown in England and were fairly rare
elsewhere in Western Europe if you go
back to the beginning of of the time
period of this chapter back to 1200 you
see one of the reasons for the rarity of
the carriage and that is that it was
considered to be shameful for a man to
ride in a wheeled vehicle in the eleven
70s clay tienda de Foix wrote a long
poem and old French called the knight of
the cart and the knight of the cart is
Sir Lancelot and Guinevere has been
kidnapped by an evil person and somebody
has to go and rescue Guinevere so
various Knights rushed off including
Lancelot and who is crazy mad in love
with Guinevere and on his quest he loses
his horse having lost his horse he still
has to go and rescue Guinevere so he
comes upon a farmer who is making his
way along a forest path in a cart and he
he hitches a ride by doing this he has
committed a shameful act
that cannot be undone he will now be
known as the knight of the cart the
knight who did something so shameful as
to get in a wheeled vehicle this had
been for hundreds of years in the post
Roman period a standard of European
society it appears men could not ride in
cars or wagons and retain their dignity
as men there are instances on record
where you have rulers or high Nobles who
are supposed to attend some important
event who will send a messenger to say
that the individual is not in sufficient
health to ride a horse because if he
didn't come on horseback then he might
as well not come at all because we
riding on a horse was simply wrong
our riding on a vehicle was simply wrong
you had to ride on a horse everybody
rode on a horse or a mule or on a on a
donkey or on a hinny whatever they had
but riding was the way you the way you
went the only exceptions were for women
of the highest rank of course there were
exceptions for for serfs the peasants
could take a ride because they had no no
dignity to lose besides if you are on a
farm you might actually need a cart for
bringing the harvest or something of
that sort but for anyone of any rank
they couldn't do it and
there were you know women who became
notable let's say richard ii of
england's wife and of bohemia was an
expert at riding sidesaddle and she kind
of set the example for a for the english
noble women that they really had to get
out there and get on a horse and not
travel around in a wheeled vehicle so
this comes to an end in the 1500 s by
the early the very say the first decade
of the 1600s there is a bill being
considered in parliament in england to
restrict the use of carriages why
because they are driving the the water
taxi people on the thames river out of
business because everyone now has a
carriage so you know between 0 carriages
in 1500 and carriages becoming the
standard for the nobility by 1600 you
have a revolution in transportation well
you might say well why single out the
transportation system i'd simply point
out that when we deal with modern
history that say the 19th or 20th
century transportation is one of our
chief areas of study railroads and then
bicycles then automobiles down to the
present day
we have considered transportation both
the ways of moving and the surfaces upon
which wheeled vehicles move we have
considered this to be a cutting edge of
an index of the change in a society you
know who builds cars how many do they
build you know will the electric car
come the signature vehicle of the Obama
administration who knows but we have
considered transportation to be of
enormous importance wheeled transport
for 19th or 20th century history and yet
we have paid almost no attention to the
startup of this which goes back to the
sixteenth century but in Western Europe
not in Eastern Europe in Eastern Europe
it goes back not just to the to the 15th
century but indeed to the 14th century
this is one of the reasons why in
talking about Latin Europe but not
including Eastern Europe or the Ottoman
areas of southeastern Europe we miss one
of the great developments of the time
because the the carriage or the coach
seems to have become popular first in
Hungary there is no real disagreement on
this
not necessarily because the only
historian is written about in this area
but everyone seems to agree with this
what he says coach is a Hungarian word
and the practice spreads from east to
west so that you find German princes
will adopt a carriage Oh a generation or
two or more before you will find the
carriage being adopted in France or
England so here is a a change that is
that is coming from the east what is it
that has changed what is a coach what is
a carriage the Romans had had four
wheeled vehicles and indeed we can trace
four wheeled vehicles back into
prehistory in Europe back to old
somewhere around 3500 BC so it's it's
not a completely new idea but the coach
had had certain improvements that have
been much debated in the sort of arcane
scholarly literature of the subject
there are five essential elements that
are part of the debate one of them is
changes in the harnessing of animals and
there is agreement that from around ten
hundred onward perhaps a little bit
earlier there are new ways of harnessing
horses that come to be known in Europe
there is disagreement there are two new
types but both of them amount to the
same thing that is to say ways of
harnessing horses that increase the
pulling efficiency of the horses so
that's one thing that
that happens shownu harnessing but that
is several hundred years before the
coach develops secondly you have the
question of of steering with a
two-wheeled vehicle which is the vehicle
of choice for every rational wheel user
in the world prior to motor transport
steering is not a big problem when the
animal moose or the pair of animals
moves in a different direction
the cart follows them with a four
wheeled vehicle it is very different if
you've ever tried to you've gotten one
of those shopping carts with the wheels
that aren't turning right and you've
tried to maneuver around an aisle and
it's it annoys you so much you have to
pick the damn thing up and and you know
sort of muscle it around if the wheels
don't pivot you have a very hard time
making any sort of a turn except over a
very very wide radius the heavier the
weight in the cart the harder it is to
turn it so without steering without
pivoting pivoting the wheels in some way
you can't readily turn a four-wheel
vehicle now if you
if you have a four-wheel vehicle and you
have you know a wheel coming out here
another one back here the problem is
that if you are going to pivot the front
axle as soon as you start to turn the
wheel is going to hit the body of the
wagon now if you make this axle long
enough you can provide for a substantial
angle of turn but then you have a very
wide axle in a rather narrow body and
kind of a waste of your space but you
can do it the the angle that you can
turn out before it hits the body is
called the lock
in other words full lock position means
that you have turned the front axle as
far as you can without you know hitting
and blocking up against the body of the
wagon it is generally thought that in
Roman times they had pivoting front axle
that at full lock might be able to pivot
to turn in a maybe a three to five
degree turning radius this would not
permit them to be used in a city the the
curve they would follow at that smaller
a turning radius for that broad a
turning radius would not give them room
to maneuver so
without a solution to this there it was
very difficult to turn a four wheeled
vehicle if you are pulling a four
wheeled vehicle across Central Asia
through endless seas of grass you don't
really care very much about you know how
long it takes to turn because you have
you know unlimited space but if you're
talking about using a vehicle in town
and one of the things I should point out
is that this rush to have carriages in
Britain was to have carriages in town
because the roads in the country were
too rough
still for for very good inter urban
traffic so you had what what could you
do one thing you can do was to have a
big wheel here and a small wheel here so
that you can turn it and it would turn
underneath the body of the wagon and of
course if you do it just far enough your
tip over but you know you could find
ways to to solve that so whenever you
see pictures of medieval or early modern
vehicles you'll notice that in most
cases the front wheels are of a smaller
diameter than the rear wheels in order
to allow for this front axle to to pivot
but of course the smaller the diameter
of the wheel the the more difficulty it
has on a rough surface because don't be
besides a bump it can go over is going
to be much smaller another possibility
would be to have a vehicle with a back
wheel here a driver's seat up here and a
front wheel hope that is that is not
under the body of wagon at all but
rather it is under the driver's seat and
this becomes characteristic of most
carriage designs that
you have the pivoting front axle goes
under the driver's seat rather than
under the body of the vehicle I can go
into tedious detail on this and perhaps
I already have I can see but but the
point is that this the the new
experiments in pivoting the front axle
in order to allow the vehicle to turn at
a fairly sharp angle are really a right
around 1,400 and they seem to start as I
say in Hungary now the next thing you
have is his brakes if you have a
two-wheeled cart your the pair of oxen
or horses you have they can pull so much
and if you're going downhill they can
hold back that same amount of weight if
you have a larger number of animals the
animals that are closest to the vehicle
can hold back more weight than the ones
that are farther away you don't have a
very efficient braking mechanism but you
can carry more and more weight in the
vehicle because you have more more and
more animals pulling up because of the
new harnessing so you had to devise ways
to to brake the vehicle as it was going
down hill and so we have various new
theories of braking such as to to lock
the wheel so it won't turn and be one
way of breaking another way would be to
basically throw out an anchor so you're
dragging something behind you that will
slow you down there is the fear of
course that when you're going uphill and
you stop you'll slide backwards again
this is for carriages in San Francisco
and so they have the idea that if you
put out a pointed stick that has the
right angle you won't go backwards
because it will dig into the pavement
which is there's no pain
dig into the dirt so you have a whole
bunch of theories on breaking and then
of course the one where you have a huge
lever you pull on the lever and it rubs
against the wheel and slows down the
rotation of the wheel so braking is
another thing that you have with
four-wheel vehicles and you don't have
with too little vehicles but you don't
have it before this time because before
this time the harnessing really is
almost unused exclusively with a pair of
animals that can break themselves
sufficiently so now you have braking
then you have the question of suspension
the surfaces that wheeled vehicles were
pulled over were generally extremely
rough even when they were paved they're
often paved with cobblestones or logs or
things that were basically very very
rough and if you were in the country
you're you know going through ruts and a
on a dirt road this made it extremely
uncomfortable for the people inside and
if the people inside were princesses who
were capable of feeling you know the
discomfort of a pee through a whole
stack of mattresses as we all know from
our fairytale background if you had
princesses of such sensibility they
needed to have some kind of suspension
so we have evidence of suspension that
go back to the Roman period indeed the
Celts who were sort of the first cart
drivers in Northern Europe had a type of
suspension system for their two-wheeled
vehicles the Romans had something of a
suspension system but then that
disappears in the medieval period and
reappears just as the pivoting front
axle disappears and then reappears you
have suspension disappearing and then it
it reappears it reappears basically as
though as a hammock slung between two
uprights and then of course you can put
up you know the top over it so nobody
sees you riding in the hammock
we actually have in medieval manuscripts
images of hammocks that are suspended in
this way and we have one text that
describes in some detail
once you have thought of the idea of
suspending a hammock then it is a it's a
fairly narrow step the wheels are
obviously down here to have to saying
well instead of a hammock let us put
some chains or straps and then put a
passenger compartment you know and drop
it down on top of the chains or straps
and let it sway and bounce along so the
first suspension were literally
suspensions then you had the idea that
instead of having the straps widened
have a spring so you would have a metal
spring in the place of the straps and
eventually you get other types of
Springs we get modern suspension and all
of these were devices to to make it more
comfortable to ride in
so you have
more efficient harnessing you have
steering your brakes you have suspension
that's four and then the fifth one is
the is the road surface as the wheels
particularly those front wheels get
smaller you have to pay more attention
to the to the road surface so highways
or more often streets within cities
gradually come to be paved very
gradually it's very expensive to pave to
pay of something because you have to
maintain it
and and the investment in in paving and
maintaining highways explains most of
federal government in the Eisenhower
administration it's a it's a huge
commitment but and it's a commitment
that is was related in the medieval
period to the building of canals because
you had canals or rebuilt in order to go
from city to city by water and a canal
was basically cheaper than a road
because after all canal doesn't need to
be kept up the water is sort of
self-replenishing but the canal is slow
so as would later happen between canals
and railroads in the United States you
have a you know issue of trade-offs
between one mode of transportation
another mode of transportation so early
on when you had carriages they they were
mostly in town between town you had
stagecoaches that were there are various
names for them that were very rough to
travel to travel in but you could go
from one of one town to another in a
stagecoach and these develop in
in the 1600s okay so if you were going
to do a history of transportation you
would say what is really striking about
Europe taking off is that it it becomes
mobile but then you would raise the
question of what about all these men
that can't ride in vehicles you know
well you know which came first the you
know the man who was such a wuss that he
would ride in the vehicle or the vehicle
for him to ride him and so one of the
one of the things that has hidden him in
the history of wheeled transport is a
history of the change in the ideology of
European men why did European men after
hundreds of years of feeling that riding
a horse was the only dignified way to
travel why did they shift not only to
riding in carriages but to competing for
the grandiosity of their carriages
because from 1600 onward
having a grand carriage and then later
having any number of vehicles that would
be specialized for display or for speed
or for some other visibly desirable
purpose becomes more and more important
down to the era of planned obsolescence
of us motorcars in the post-world War
two period you know wheeled vehicles
become an obsession among a prosperous
class of people who several centuries
before had regarded it as shameful to
ride in a wheeled vehicle that isn't
that interesting
this is something that has absolutely
nothing to do with the Muslim world
because you had no real vehicles in the
Muslim world everybody who trance who
went from place place in the Muslim
world went there by by foot or riding on
an animal or by being carried in a sedan
chair by human Porter's but in Europe
you went from having men who wrote on
horses two men who who rode in carriages
so something's happening to to the male
mentality that only shows up in there
and their willingness to change their
mode of transport now most men of rank
continued to ride horses this is not a
this is not something up sweeps that
sweeps the continent you can go down to
the 19th century and find times when
monarchs who are going to be crowned
will ride to their coronation on a horse
because it's the old noble way to do it
I think that Tsar Nicholas the enough
nicholas ii wrote on a horse to be
crowned but I think his predecessor did
so it isn't a complete change but to the
degree that this change occurs it's
related to the disappearance of the of
the night the reason men did not ride on
vehicles was because knighthood required
that they be equestrians so that if
Lancelot the knight rides in the cart he
is forever shamed if boto the peasant
rides on the cart hey that's his way of
getting from here to there so that
beneath this whole business of the
change in wheeled vehicles you have
changes in the military
and the changes of the military have to
do with the new vulnerability of the
night this doesn't mean that Knights
were not eminent warriors in the 1500s
or before that in the 1400s it's just
that they were eminent obsolete warriors
they had become more and more display
soldiers whose armor was incredibly
elegant but it was display armor it was
to be used in tourneys or JAUS but it
wasn't really battlefield armor if you
go every go through the armor section in
the Metropolitan you'll find beautiful
suits of armor and the and it will be
explained in the in the commentary that
this is display armor meant not to be
actually worn in a battlefield because
most of the suits of armor are late the
late suits of armor are the most elegant
because they're for display and the
early suits of armor are beat up and
have holes in them because you know
that's what happens with armor you get
hit by something you have a damped no I
got a ding in my chest for my heart was
so-so the decline of the knight is is
part of this the decline of the knight
is related to the rise of gunpowder
now our restricted chapter that deals
with the Latin West says that by the
time of the Battle of Crecy French
artillery had become effective and so
forth and so on
but gunpowder weapons are used in the
1300s
and are used most effectively in Eastern
in southeastern Europe not in Western
Europe it's well known that in the siege
of Constantinople in 1453 when the
Ottomans bring the Byzantine Empire to
an end that large cannon were used to to
blow holes in the walls
but those cannon were forged on the spot
for a big siege weapon it would be too
heavy for you to actually move it across
country so instead you bring wagons or
baskets of strapped bronze or scrap iron
and you build a forge there you know
outside the walls and the peaceful
people looking on the walls and saying
what are they doing that and and then
you forge a cannon and then you load the
cannon with you know cannonballs this
big around you lob them at the walls and
the walls are are destroyed and you're
able to take the city but that isn't the
only way to use gunpowder weapons I
mentioned last time that the Janissary
Corps of the Ottoman Empire carried
handheld weapons from the they were in
infantry but there they were not as
advanced in their use of of small
gunpowder weapons as the Bohemians who
are the followers of yan who's see
another thing by we we don't cover the
Reformation in this chapter because we
say the Reformation is Martin Luther but
yon who's is a generation before Martin
Luther generation no more and is not in
Western Europe but rather in Bohemia
which is now the Czech Republic yon
who's was a significant reformer
he was inspired by the movement of John
Wickliffe John Wickliffe was an English
radical who believed that common people
should be able to read the Bible in
their own language who had a large
following and his message was combated
by the Catholic Church he was in too
firm a position in England to be
personally killed but the movement was
stamped out by the by the church however
I mentioned before that an of Bohemia
the wife of Richard ii was an expert a
sidesaddle rider she also as someone who
after the death of her husband returned
to Bohemia and with her came a number of
ADEs and followers who had been
influenced by John Wickliffe so when
John who's is becoming a radical from a
Catholic point of view in Bohemia he has
access to the teachings of John
Wickliffe and you get this this
influence in religious reform moving
from a populist version of of
Christianity in England to to the check
the check area which is Bohemia which is
the area north of Vienna yon whose was a
professor and he was you know at the
University of Prague and there were all
sorts of complications there since the
university of prague had as a number of
universities had they had
for several different nations so if you
were a student it would belong to one
nation or another and there are four
nations the University of Prague of
which the Bohemians were one nation and
then you have the Germans you had the
poles so forth the kid the King of
Bohemia changed things and said that the
Bohemian should have three votes instead
of one vote and so all the other
students left and found it went and
founded universities elsewhere that's
how the University of Leipzig and
eastern Germany gets founded as refugees
from the university of prague who had
belonged to the nation of the Germans so
yon hoose becomes the head of the
university and maintains that that the
bohemian form the bohemian people should
have their own say in matters of
religion this comes to a head when some
of those followers receive a delegation
of people who who are trying to talk
sense to them and they throw them out
the window this is what's known as the
defenestration of Prague they're not
hurt when they thrown out the window
they land in a haystack I think but it
leads on to the trial and conviction of
yon who's who is who is burned at the
stake
this being the ingenious Roman Catholic
response to heresy in that and that
timeframe okay the followers of yon
who's become warlike and they proceed to
to fight a series of wars a series of
wars in which their antagonists are
Crusaders sent by the papacy there are
five Crusades against the Christians of
ohey Mia by the Christians inspire
following the Pope in order to suppress
the Hussites
those wars are won fairly systematically
by the Hussites and the reason they win
is because they have superior military
techniques what do they have they have
four wheeled vehicles that they turn
into tanks basically they you have a
series of vehicles and so forth you
chain them together you turn it you make
them into a circle and then on their
outer walls you have windows that open
and you shoot out of the windows with
gunpowder weapons with small a small
cannon and this this circling of the
wagons becomes the you know the signal
contribution to warfare to to military
tactics by the sights but it also
demonstrates for the first time the the
use of vehicles in battle that are not
chariots because Chris Hill chariot
going back to ancient times carried the
warrior carry the warrior to the battle
and maybe even provided a base for the
warrior to fight from the chariot
although in the Iliad they get out of
the chariot to do the fighting but here
you have the vehicle being used to have
protected warriors inside a closed
wooden box or where they cannot easily
be reached and they can shoot at people
who are outside you notice we've all
seen western movies where the Cowboys or
the the cavalry best the Indians by
doing exactly this sort of thing thought
they'd never get in the wagons they
always are hiding behind the wheels or
something like that I don't know why
they don't get in the wagons but whose
sights knew better than that so
so now you have the the idea of wheels
and and gunpowder together and I think
it is out of this that you have evolved
the notion of field artillery where you
actually carry a cannon on wheels
usually on two wheels and then you carry
your cannonballs and other equipment on
a limber which is basically a little
wagon that goes along along with the
cannon and cannon become mobile instead
of like the ones you had in 1453 where
you just have a procedure puces
gradually you evolve mobile cannon and
the night's become less and less
relevant and artillery comes in the
process of the 1600s to be the real
queen of the other military sciences
it's out of the artillery core that
Napoleon eventually emerges as the
greatest military thinker of of his era
so the Knights are becoming obsolete the
notion that they can't that they have to
ride on a horse
because equestrian training is inherent
to their class position that seems to to
erode fairly naturally I don't know of
any test case having to do with them but
one of the striking things about
carriages is that the carriage can be
bought by anyone who's rich enough
you know it is not a something that is
restricted to a particular segment of
society in other words the Duke of X
could be an aristocrat could have a
carriage but so could a prosperous
merchant or a you know a successful
person of any sort if he could afford if
he could afford a carriage so when you
get into the area of of a new wheeled
society you're talking about new markers
of distinction that instead of being a
war horse and armor and a coat of arms
you're having a grandiose carriage and
you're beginning to reduce some of the
difference between the early aristocracy
as people of wealth and the the
wealthier members of the of the
commonality now finally I want to make
reference to another theory that I'm not
going to go into and that is one that
comes out of economics that maintains
and walking on the name of the author
right now but it maintains that the the
rise of the of the Maxima of the
rational maximizing Homo economicus
explains the process of technological
change it's in a book called does
technology determine history the
argument is that if you don't have a
transparent market in which you people
can buy goods
and the best goods they can afford then
change will be restricted in various in
various ways and more or less haphazard
once you have an open market then
competition the the Adam Smithian market
will actually regulate the distribution
of goods in the way we've seen so
effective in 2008 so that so that the
super-rich get super richer and everyone
else no sucks them up that's uh but but
but the point is that he argued that
technological change becomes inevitable
once you have reached the point where
you have a capitalist market this is not
a Protestant mentality but rather a
capitalist marketplace and by knocking
down the economic distinctions between
nobility and common law and commoners
and saying you can buy some shoe Airy
goods like carriages if you have enough
money you get to profit you know profit
maximizing individuals who will want to
make more money so they can buy better
things and they will devise ways and
means of making more money by producing
better and more interesting products and
that Europe gets triggered into a into
sort of a cascade of technological
improvement because of the birth of the
profit maximizing consumer now the
problem with this is that it assumes
what have many problems with this but
the one that that grabs me is that it
assumes that you know what people want
that profit maximizing is going to is
going to be primarily oriented into our
marketplace but if your notion of
maximizing your happiness to go back to
the way Aristotle would look at it you
know what is the end of of human life
its happiness if max y near happiness
not having more money but rather having
a reputation for piety or maximizing
your happiness has to do with changing
your rank buying your way into a
nobility for example or maximizing your
happiness has to do with assuring your
entrance to heaven which might mean you
know eating you know gruel and growths
for 50 years and living in the forest
without any underwear on you know there
are so many different ways than you that
societies conceive of maximizing their
happiness that the assumption that the
that the market of buying better and
more desirable goods is going to be the
dominant one is not necessarily a safe
assumption but it does seem to work for
Europe the Europeans do then seem to
want to buy more and better things and
produce more and better things so they
get a more profit to buy more and better
things and that gets back to this issue
why does this start I mean we have any
number of books now that will talk about
comparisons between Europe and China or
Europe and India or something like that
and show that the various material
levels Europe wasn't that different but
Europe does something different and we
don't really know why my bet is on
transportation but but that's just me
and it's less I'll say on this and this
semester because next week I'm going to
talk about maritime matters and not
about land transport